what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar in here I am back with another
how strong is video the response of my
how strong is tantra video was amazing
and many space Famers said they wanted
more so I'm excited to present this
video focusing on zeti to strength if
you want to keep seeing these demons
their videos make sure to smash that
like button to let me know if we can get
4000 likes I'll start working on the
next one
ASAP if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bow so you
actually get notified when you would
even say your videos drop for more demon
Surtur content and crucial updates about
the upcoming movie and seasons follow us
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
linked in the description if you didn't
guess by now there will be manga
spoilers in this video because we are
going to use all the information
available to figure out how strong sites
who actually is and without further ado
let's jump into it best boys any to
definitely doesn't start off as a strong
dude he's actually presented like a
cowardly weakling in the beginning
he's always doubting his own power and
worried that he's about to die yet the
talent is there even when we get
flashbacks design to training with his
sensei we see that the former Thunder
pillar jig or Okajima
believed inside it soon no matter how
many times they need to ran away and
said that he couldn't produce any
results his sensei brought him back and
told him that he's got the talent
sidenote thunder style is sometimes
translated as lightning style but I'll
just be using thunder style for this
video anyways the former Thunder pillar
believed in sunny - and that's very
significant
not only was Giotto a pillar according
to keikaku he was a person who received
the title the strongest demon hunter so
the fact that such a strong person who
could have his pick of students refuses
to give up on xeni - shows that there is
definitely amazing potential in him the
Saints who could only learn one of the
six forms of the breadth of Thunder
style the first is considered to be the
most basic form so sunny - thought he
was a failure because he couldn't learn
the rest however his sensei showed him
how to turn this seeming weakness into a
strength
instead of going broad and getting a
fundamental understanding of every form
said it's who could go deep and master
first form better than anyone else when
life gives you lemons make lemonade and
when life gives you one breath of the
Thunder for
make it the most badass attack possible
his sensei tells any to to use the first
form as much as he can to work on it
until he's reached the limit of the
limit his sensei tells him to go to
distance he says that he can run he can
cry but he can't give up not only does
the sensei believe that he can become a
great swordsman he believes that he can
become stronger than anyone else so
clearly is that he too has a lot of
potential the man once called the
strongest demon hunter believes that he
can become the strongest however he is
in the process of developing himself so
let's see how far he's gotten so far
when we first season to confront a demon
in the drumhouse the overwhelming fear
and sense of responsibility he feels
causes him to pass out he literally
falls asleep when he needs to be
protecting people it looks like it's all
over when suddenly the demons attacking
tongue gets cut off the Saints who gets
up and signals for the kid present to
get behind him while asleep he cuts off
the monsters head with one quick slash
he looks like a complete badass until he
wakes up and starts freaking out at the
sight of a severed demon head all those
sightings who doesn't even know what
happened the narrator steps in to assure
us that semi-to has I stopping
swordsmanship skills if we didn't
already pick that up from his impressive
attack soul science was strong from the
beginning of the series it's just that
his fears hinder him from consciously
using those powers however once
unconscious he is free from fears and
hesitation and is able to show his
skills with each battles that each who
gets better and better at using his
powers while he's conscious the gross
older brother spider is an opponent that
would freak out anyone he injects a su
with poison and xeni - starts turning
into a spider he even starts losing his
hair during this battle again it appears
like science who passes out from fear
and falls out of a tree but he appears
to be thinking now and even opens his
eyes at one point the spiders surprised
with Zaitsev skills and marvels at how
he was able to turn his body midair and
dodge despite how much the poison is
hurting Sonny - and making it harder for
him to move science who succeeds in
beating the demon spider and he doesn't
just beat him he crushes him he uses
breath of thunder first form
thunderclap flash like he did before but
this time he makes it six-fold this
allows him to move like lightning his
speed is immense
he moves in six different directions
before hitting the spider yet st. was so
fast that the spider still had no time
to react after he defeats a spider demon
he thinks about a happy dream where he
is stronger than anyone else so now he
like his sensei has faith that he can
become the strongest he does have the
potential as long as he doesn't give up
in the fight against Upper Moon sects
stocky and guitarra Saints who still
looks like he's sleeping but he can
communicate with tan Jiro he uses the
first form but Eightfold this time daki
saw his previous attack so she thinks
that she knows the limits of his speed
however then saying she uses God speed
daki and upper moon can't help but call
Sciences movements so fast he can only
use God speed twice and then his legs
will become useless at this point but
the second time is enough to take da
keys head thanks to a little help from
eNOS K Wednesday to fully wakes up he's
surprised that his whole body hurts and
that his legs are broken but the fact
remains that he was fast enough to
impress an upper moon and strong enough
to play a crucial role in their defeat
now we get to the fight between thos
former senpai kagaku this fight is the
best example of where science was power
is currently at and during this fight he
doesn't fall asleep it's actually funny
because any to usually looks scared when
he confronts a powerful opponent and
kagaku is the strongest opponent he's
had to confront all by himself yet
despite the fact that he has to fight an
upper moon by himself he looks like an
absolute savage not only does he not act
scared
he seems 100% committed to absolutely
crushing kagaku he even insults kagaku
by calling him a stopgap which is a
temporary way of dealing with a problem
or satisfying a need in other words
science was saying that KY gaku was only
given the title of upper moon six
because they needed someone to fill the
role and not because he's actually
strong enough to deserve it there is
some truth to this guy gaku is a
relatively new demon so hasn't had much
time to get used to his new demon powers
nevertheless as mentioned he is the
strongest opponents and who has fought
against alone so let's take a look at
how he does is a qu is extremely angry
with Kai Goku because his sensei the
only one who believed in him and his
ability committed ritual suicide when
Kai Goku another one of his students
willingly turned into a D
not only did a sense they kill himself
no one was even there to properly
execute the ritual so sunny - sensei
suffered a long and agonizing death
kakaako doesn't care though because
their sensei didn't want to give him the
successorship G Goro wanted kagaku and
xeni two to share the successorship this
is also an important clue when it comes
to signing through strength
it is good his sensei felt that Zen e2
was strong enough to share the
successorship with kagaku and this was
when Zainichi was weaker than he is now
Tenga ku always used to be stronger than
zetsu and now his power is amplified by
his demon transformation yet senate's
who cannot only keep up he calls kagaku
to slow kagaku uses his best attacks on
Sonny - and he definitely injures him
but not enough is any to use a new form
he's been keeping a secret it is a form
he's created for himself called flaming
Thunder God while Kai Goku has been
fighting to kill Sonny - the whole time
thanks who has been fighting while also
feeling bad for Kai Goku he wishes they
could have worked together he says sorry
Ani ki aka sorry big brother before
using his secret move to finish him off
in reality it seems exciting's who could
have used this move earlier a lot to
finish Kai Goku but he held back either
in order to gain Kai gaku strength or in
order to mentally prepare to finish off
the person he used to look up to this
attack is extremely strong and fast
further style users are fast in general
and kagaku speed is further enhanced by
his upper moon demon powers yet
senex whose technique is so fast he can
close a significant distance before
kagaku can even react furthermore the
attack is strong enough to easily cut
through his neck even though upper Moon
X can be especially tough to cut it's
also telling that the attack forms a
shape of a dragon one of the most
powerful of mythical creatures and has
God in the title implying that it
reaches a superhuman divine level it is
clear that with this attack se2 has
significantly passed kagaku and skill
despite his demon upgrades in fact after
the attack high gaku said that he
couldn't even see the attack the senator
was too fast so sites who successfully
overpowered a demon moon now to be fair
he did have to be rescued in the end
from falling to his death and from his
injuries and ushiro confirmed
kagaku had no idea how to use his own
techniques and abilities he called sunny
- lucky because if he fought kagaku a
year later he would have died on the
spot however I don't think this is an
entirely fair assessment for instance is
he assuming that sunny - when it gets
stronger in a year given the rate of
growth of both Dodger runs and - over
the show so far I'd say that in a year
saying she was going to be a lot
stronger - decided to sense a one of the
strongest pillars ever believed that
sunny - could become the strongest so I
think he has mad potential to grow also
kagaku was inexperienced but there is no
doubt that you need to meet a certain
and impressive standard before they'll
give you an upper moon title and he
evidently met it lastly I do have the
feeling that settings who could have
finished the battle earlier with his
secret attack if he had less emotions
like pity and regret causing him to hold
back longer than necessary as of now I'd
say he is at least pillar level we are
told by the narrator when Muccino beat
up ur moon 5 that a pillar managing to
the feet and upper moon demon is a
really unnatural situation now I
wouldn't put Zetas to a muchos level yet
because kagaku as mentioned was lower
ranking and inexperienced when compared
to upper moon 5 however still the fact
that Zenit su could be an upper moon by
himself speaks volumes about his power
if it's even unnatural for a pillar to
beat 1 and sunny - isn't even a pillar
yet saying to us proven that he can
consciously use his power now to
effectively accomplish things that some
pillars never accomplished namely to
kill an upper moon for instance the
former sound pillar needed a lot of help
from Zetas - tundra and eNOS K for them
to eventually defeat Upper Moon sects
dokyun guitarra the love pillar needed
on zero to defeat upper moon for yet
send it to overpower the new upper moon
six by such an extent that kagaku
couldn't even follow his movements for
this reason I'd currently even consider
putting zetsu ahead of most pillars who
have yet to access the see-through world
the see-through world seems to be
something that only the most skilled
demon Slayers have accessed so far like
Tangier ochio me and mu Ichiro
although I don't think he's as strong as
Tantra right now I do think that Zen e2
has made huge progress and that he is
Mouse
enough that he could help rather than
get in the way in any upcoming battle
and that is how strong I think science
was currently I think that he is strong
and especially fast even compared to
pillars and like his sensei I think that
he has the potential to eventually rival
even the quickly evolving ton judo in
power anyways if you enjoyed this make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know if you have and be sure to
subscribe and ring that notification
bell so you actually get notified when
you do miss her videos drop let me know
whose strength you'd like to see broken
down next for a crucial updates on the
upcoming Demon Slayer movie and seasons
follow us on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar a big thank you goes out to
our patrons over on patreon who help
make videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our Pro hero to
your patrons don't one-and-only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King cell dressed angel Cruz Steelers
poet Pablo
atropos Wraith Finney dolla beat and a
qiraji end and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans Steven
and raava al-hola autumn Maddie Mac 239
and makoto-kun if you enjoy our work you
can support more of it by going over to
patreon.com slash anime uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little as
$1 if you do so you'll get your name
feature in future videos alongside these
pillars right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]
[Music]